hello this is matthias from datatec and
in this video i would like to show you
how you can easily order online
you first have to
go to date up de and also
press
charts if you want to use your own data
click once here on table
learn i have now  once an
example data set prepared in this
example data set of people asked
which video service they
use so you can have a netflix
or disney whether you live in the city or in
the country and what your monthly
income
i just copy this
data set from excel  and copy it
here in the table so i do
n't want to have any bar charts
and no programs either but a box
bot so i click here on parking lot now
i see the metric variable in
cham here i can just
click on it and i get  a box
there for the variable in cham I would now like to
split the variable h  Aben
in the various video streaming
service means he just needs to click here on the right
just at nominal rate video service
now I get three box
space with amazon netflix and
disney I would also like to have the
division according to the place of residence so
whether I was in the city on
live in the country what an influence that has on the one in
cham i just click
on it here too now i get a group
box where i have the
city group once and the countryside group once
would like to have the division different
i just think of the  arrow right
and get the groups amazon
helfrichs and is in every box there
i now see the minimum value q1 the
median value mean value q3 and the
maximum value
it is so easy to create a bock there with data tab
i hope you liked the video